I want to UM I want to visualize your
your lineage quickly so let's go to your
teacher is Francis Lucile correct and
you did you meet him around 1995 ish or
when 1997 97 okay and then for 13 years
you studied with him so up until about
2010 or so yes let me just go back a
little bit further yes and to my late
teens where I first became interested in
these matters
and so I started attending a school or a
society in in London called a study
Society and it was essentially a school
of classical Advaita Vedanta so for 20
years or so I was in this classical
inviter teaching practicing mantra
meditation and exploring the classical
non dual teachings and it was after 20
years of that that I then met Francis
yes he introduced me to the the direct
approach and he also introduced me to
the tantric approach which he had
learned through his teacher Jean Klein
yes and as you then spent 13 years or so
with Francis before I started speaking
about these matters myself yes yes very
few people have the opportunity to be
introduced to non duality at the age of
16 which is what you had that's true I
was fortunate my mother and stepfather
at the time were both very interested in
these matters they originally went to
college how's that the study Society in
London and so they introduced me to call
it house the advisor teaching they also
practice the Mevlevi turning
and so I was introduced I was very
fortunate at an early age during my mid
to late teens to come across this
understanding to meet a lot of people
and spend really most of my time with a
with a lot of people most of them older
than me at that time who were interested
in these matters so this really from a
mid teens up until my mid thirties the
this the class color advisor or non-dual
approach was really the the backdrop to
my life and was really the main focus of
my life during those years and in
Francis's lineage goes to Jean Klein who
he met in 1975 and then and then and
then Jean Klein was with Panditji Rao in
1950 and punditji was a professor of
Sanskrit in Bangalore and Lin he came
from a Linde lineage of advaita teachers
yes that's true Jean was also a yoga
teacher so what was unusual about you
John Klein and I think he meant to be
valuable is is that he his approach
incorporated the body and didn't reject
the body and and indeed the world as
some of the classical I divided the
teachings coming out of India did so
this was the this is what I referred to
earlier as the tantric approach which is
an approach of inclusion you're
including the totality of the experience
rather than the masculine vitae approach
where the the body and the world are
considered at least in some expressions
of a dark are considered dangerous
realms where we might lose ourselves so
on so that was something very valuable
immensely valuable the Francis
introduced me to this this inclusive
path yes as I pose to the path of
exclusion or the path of discrimination
which which don't get me wrong I have
the highest
regard for and spent 20 years on that
past myself and it was immensely
valuable but there was something
incomplete about it for me because of
this lack of inclusion of the body and
the world and of course during these
early years I was practicing as you said
earlier as a Potter I was spending my my
days making pots in my studio my and my
nights reading ramana maharshi as a
potter i I loved things I spent my life
making things I loved things I love
beauty and so there was no question of
me renouncing yes objects also it wasn't
until I met Francis that this that that
my love of beauty that I was exploring
in my studio by day and my love of truth
that I was exploring at home by night
really came together and I realized that
really the love of beauty in the love of
truth are indeed the same thing yes yes
and this is this is key and we're going
to touch on this throughout our
conversation is this full embrace of the
beauty of what is what we have here and
the full unleashing of of inner
potential artistry gifts into our into
our reality I want to I want to relate
what you just said also to Sri Aurobindo
quickly and the mother mere al fossa and
integral yoga in the sense that they
also highly highly emphasized the
importance of anchoring the divine
anchoring the full embodiment in every
day and that way it basically butterfly
effects out into everything that we do
with our family our friends our work our
relationships everything and that's the
the process of the
the beginnings of a more beautiful and
truthful and unde wakin to the true
nature of reality world yes yes